which teams up with Emma for the dance  of romance although suffering a broken  nose the spelling was  Alek skarlatos is recovering from a  possible broken nose after being elbowed  by switch a partner and the Slater how  did you feel about that Oh like how does  it feel like do you feel like it's  broken I don't know it kind of Wiggles a  little bit when I touch it on this side  so we'll find out fingers crossed he  told me they actually broke it back into  place I guess so he was like actually  it's all right derek hough is no  stranger to injury on the dance floor  the pro dancer hurt his foot last season  and spent a night in the ER but  surprisingly that's not his scariest  accident dancing in competition I bit my  tongue in half it was dangling down and  like blood was falling out all that my  rhinestones there it's pretty crazy